another by-election to face what on
Earth is going on tomorrow well he may
well do you because this is a report
we've just seen into Chris pincher
you'll remember he was Boris Johnson's
deputy chief Whip and he played quite
important role in the downfall of Boris
Johnson because although we often
attribute it to all the Saga around
partygate in fact the final straw was
when
um it emerged that Chris pincher was
accused of groping uh two men at a
private members Club at an event Last
Summer the Downing Street in the Prime
Minister were asked if they'd had any
concerns raised with them about his
conduct before they appointed him to
that role Downing Street said they
hadn't it then transpired the Prime
Minister had been told of concerns now
this is a report by the standards
commissioner into those allegations and
they say that they recommend essentially
an eight-week suspension for Mr pincher
which does raise the prospect of a
by-election in his Tamworth Constitution
agency because anything over 10 days
triggers a recall petition in which the
voters in that constituency can choose
to remove him just reading through this
report is pretty damning
um as to whether Mr pincher breached the
code of conduct for MPS which is uh says
that they mustn't cause significant
damage to the reputation of the house
they the the commissioner says Mr
pinch's conduct was deeply inappropriate
and shameful and the Damage that has
been caused to the reputation and
integrity of the house and members of
parliament cannot be described as
trivial or noteworthy or not important
to address they say the behavior here
was shocking deeply inappropriate
and adversely impacted these two
unsuspecting individuals and they
describe a man who was at this all took
place at the Carlton Club in central
London and private members Club popular
with conservatives Mr pincher was
described as being extremely drunk went
up to him out he'd never met before and
started to Grape him touch him
inappropriately a number of times and
then do that with a second person and
both of them Describe the impact that it
had on them now um Chris pincher did not
give evidence in person to this
committee but did write to them saying
I'm conscious of the effect the evening
and the coverage must have had on all
the parties involved and he says he's
very sorry as he was when he resigned
from the government although he denies
breaching that bit of the code so just
to clarify the fact that he they're
recommending that he is suspended from
the service of the house for eight weeks
is what it says here as a result this is
accepted then um there could well be
another by-election
yes the government already facing four
by-elections the three the the ones that
they've got um on the 20th of July
um these are Boris Johnson supporters
standing down and indeed a Boris
Johnson's constituency Nadine dory's
by-election we expect to happen and now
we've got this last last one potentially
in Tamworth so potentially a fifth one
for the Prime Minister if MPS accept
this report which I imagine they will
and if voters in his constituency uh
vote in this petition to remove him now
rather than wait for him to stand down
um before the general election because
we understand he's not going to be
running again so the prospect of another
by-election by elections in which
someone is accused of misconduct
um either sexual misconduct or any other
misconduct tend not to go well for the
governing party so although the
conservatives achieved a 20 000 majority
in that seat at the last election it was
a labor seat prize 2010 and of course
they can't be complacent